question de constance comment ça marche
les disques vinyles vous avez tous tenu
un disque vinyle entre vos mains et vous
avez tous constater qu'il est creusée
par un sillon ce sillon à l'intérieur
n'est pas plat vient relief avec des
bosses et des creux qui correspondent à
la modulation du son en fait leçon de
soul il a cependant de musique ou tout
simplement le son de la voix c'est de
l'air qui vibre elle les molécules qui
composent l'air sont comprimées puis se
détendent et ce mouvement se transmet de
proche en proche jusqu'à nos oreilles
pour fabriquer un disque vinyle on
utilise cette vibration quand vous
mettez le disque le diamant du bras de
votre platine gliese dans le sillon et
en rencontres ce relief inévitablement
il se met à vibrer ses vibrations vont
générer des signaux électriques qui à
terme vont faire vibrer la membrane de
votre enceinte à la même fréquence que
les sons d'origine